so everyone out there who makes a living
pointing out systemic discrimination ask
yourself is that really the reason for
your shortcomings or could it be could
it just be that maybe you've been
looking your whole life for an excuse as
to why why you can't while other people
of the same color race gender
orientation take your pick
do so here's my question of the day and
you can tweet me at Ascot or just
comment below before we go to the next
topic as you look at the country how do
you see the country do you see any
empirical evidence today for systemic
racism for institutional racism as
opposed to anecdotal which I believe is
the fuel on which our media runs today
entirely anecdotal evidence comment
below I'm really curious Lee and why do
I say that because Starbucks is now set
to close more than 8,000 locations for
racial bias education the company said
the training would aim to address
implicit bias teach employees how to
prevent discrimination promote conscious
inclusion employees will receive the
training on and the stores will close
for the afternoon of May 29th this comes
on the heels of protests of course after
two black men were arrested at one of
the franchise's stores first off let me
prep it
it's just be honest about my biases I
like my protesters how I like my coffee
actually with lots of half-and-half in
that 2 min but I'm not really sure that
it's cinnamon but I accepted a cinnamon
anyway that's how I like my protest some
Millennials may have good work one thing
I'm tired of Millennials being the
whipping post I understand there are a
lot of Millennials out there who have
good work ethics okay I don't think that
everyone is lazy and whiny and they do
end up creating great technology some of
them are innovators but the reason why
Millennials are seen as whiney is
because of stories like this because
they create and find discrimination
where there is none the reason your
grandfather isn't super sympathetic to
your cause is because he was shot at by
Nazis in a foxhole let's read the next
quote as opposed to you with the
Starbucks in the reeducation the
protests broke out at that Starbucks
location on Monday and demonstrators
said the arrests were indicative of
institutional racism that word I do not
think it means what so we're now
declaring a Starbucks your folks to be
institutional racism
yeah and another sin because the cops
arrested Esther but again the police
were called from the Starbucks I think
it was loitering who knows what happened
there but again we're gonna protest over
institutional racism let's look at what
this action the definition of
institutional racism is as follows
institutional racism is a pattern of
social institutions such as government
organization schools banks and courts of
law giving negative treatment to a group
of people based on their race no I'm not
saying that we haven't had institutional
racism in this country and it still
exists elsewhere as you see with an
entered servitude some examples of the
United States for example being barred
from drinking from the same water
fountain as White's kind of fix that
with the Civil Rights Act of 1964 or
being prohibited from attending
all-white schools the Brown versus Board
of Education case these are examples of
institutionalized racism not being
kicked out of a Starbucks because you
refuse to buy something but I realized
doing the story I did have to check my
white privilige a bit because what with
me not remembering the often
conveniently ignored portion of Martin
Luther King Jr's speech that all men
would be able to loiter without purchase
at their local Starbucks of donuts
Dunkin or if they so desire along with
any of their colleagues be able to
purchase a $4 macchiato and I'm not a
cold brew I have a dream preached so
here's another example is racism they
are just aching the left people like
Shaun King who tweeted this out they are
just aching to find a reason they use
these anecdotal examples as a launching
pad for institutionalized racism Shaun
King just tweeted this out this video
let's let's let's watch the video and
leave Shaun King tweet this roll the
video
want to judge the rest you wanted to use
a rata now just about to go before you
made a purchase they let you use a
restroom right I just typed in my ass
for the car yes what a code and they
just gave it to you all right
before you made a purchase yeah okay all
right come on
okay come over here my iPhone 10 so this
is Weston and Weston how to make watch
it guys
so our like Starbucks right here on
Redondo Artesia and heartborne this man
right here say he hasn't made he said he
hasn't made a purchase a he didn't like
make a purchase you guys haven't get you
guys you guys had gave him the code
right is it that what you did no this is
not your business this is not your
business
this is not your business okay you maybe
permit what's your not what did I do
I just tried to use a bathroom like you
did and they got to be aggressive maybe
my skin color
absolutely so again you watch that clip
this just shows me that people like
Shaun King they don't even care anymore
when we've had clips that we roll we've
got a whole second oh wait there's some
context there sometimes I think it was a
pro gun clip at one point oh what
happened that might not happen
justification there yeah we don't run it
in this case you clearly see there was a
prior conversation to this that occurred
a cop was there and ready which means
they were probably already called before
this incident went down this guy is
acting like in in just an indignant ass
and of course there's the white guy who
was just intimidated beyond yeah was I
wait I don't even know what he was so
again let's compare this two examples of
actual institutionalized racism like
being prevented from voting because of
race right we had the Voting Rights Act
we kind of we made some progress there
being forced at not being allowed to sit
at the front of the bus that was a big
one right Rosa Parks she revolution
sitting down good for her now almost all
of these movements today if he contrasts
institutionalized racism and if you
look at that by the way they were they
were won legislatively they were won
through education whereas in this case
these incident these modern ladies we
dead these movements are won by keeping
people in the dark almost let's look
through all of the major movements in
recent memory and they the catalyst was
something anecdotes the black lives
matter
it started with Michael Brown the hands
up don't shoot lie it was the anecdote
it wasn't about police brutality wasn't
about the actual statistics as we've
covered on the show when you look at the
fact that you're actually more likely to
be shot as a white young American than a
black young American statistically we
talked about that go read a letter of
credit calm it wasn't about the women's
March the P had economics right that was
based on an Access Hollywood tape the
grand by the puppy who can forget that
that didn't have anything to do with the
wage gap which is non-existent in
evident with economics didn't have to do
with unfair treatment in the workplace
it was based on an Access Hollywood tape
that was the catalyst for everyone
marching on down the streets in which
are now not allowed because they offend
[ __ ] rapes culture offensive great a
culture no so this one is a little bit
more complicated but rape culture has
become a part of the societal vernacular
from a few main stories it was a Duke
Lacrosse case uva rape oaks the rolling
stone article and mattress girl and
guess what all of them turned out to be
hoaxes these were the anecdotal cases
that were used to say there's a rape
culture on campus from from people like
lena dunham to celebrities talking about
how there's a rape culture on campus
clearly the evidence is no there is no
evidence that's in your favor it's my
back there is zero evidence just like
there is zero evidence that women are
oppressed and there is zero evidence of
systemic institutionalized
discrimination and/or racism but rape
culture now they just people believe it
people you have Michael Ian Black on the
show you believe it Naomi Wolf blue
these are people who are professors
Barack Obama believe it they're like The
Muppet guys only instead of yep it's
rape rape rape rape rape rape rape rape
rape rape in the media goes along with
it
it's the anecdotal evidence that is used
as a springboard to mislead people so
here's what this is - by the way for
people out there who you the guy in the
bathroom you know I'm gonna do let's say
I'm talking I'm gonna do you a service
okay it's hedging your bets on failure
it's giving you an excuse for your poor
behavior for your failure because you
chalk it up to some discrimination that
doesn't exist that's the reason people
use this right now
what black lives matter is Michael Brown
and the live hands up don't shoot
excuses the burning down of Walgreens
and destroying your neighborhoods CVS I
guess I got that my Walgreens is funnier
word to say the grand by the P comment
is why you can't find a job because you
spend $50,000 under Gender Studies
degree it's a reason for why you can't
go into a little girls bathroom despite
having put on a dress and really really
really wanting to it's because President
Donald Trump said grab them by the P
it's all because of systemic
institutionalized discrimination which
you prove through your antidotes
antidotes anecdote its hedging your bets
justifying your failure and your crappy
behavior by acting as though there's
some kind of barrier to entry and in the
United States I can say definitively
there is none anymore there is no
institutionalized barrier to success
based on race gender or orientation in
2018 none none zero unless you're an
Asian with a higher than average SAT
score there are too many go back we
don't want you there too many go away
get away from Stanford we don't want
your kind around here so when activists
like David hog say that old people don't
know how to do democracy or they didn't
know how to tie dye preserve their
democracy so unfortunately we're gonna
have to take care of it for him that
little pissant well yours think these
people who don't respect Millennials
they actually fought for democracy they
actually died to say more democratically
we can go back to the World War two vets
that's why they appreciate it that's
where they think that you're a bunch of
arrogant ungrateful little pissant well
let's even just go to back to Vietnam
those veterans came back because they
were fighting communists in an
unwinnable war granted with JFK turn
into a quagmire either way they any way
you line it up they were fighting
against systemic oppression in one form
or another and guess what they came back
only to have people spit on them that's
why previous generations are not
sympathetic when you say oh I have to
take Starbucks but they wouldn't let me
because of institutionalization oh no
you're just in it and you know what by
the way that entire video you know how
that entire video could change the
context that lady at the front desk
could have asked both of them whether it
was number one or number two so oh I've
just got a pee okay no problem
I gotta take a massive dump No
is it cuz I'm black no it's more about
the massive dump thing I'm not saying
that's the context I'm trying to provide
you if they're gonna provide anecdotal
evidence with some context that might
change it so everyone out there who
makes a living off of or pointing out
systemic discrimination astir
is that really the reason for your
shortcomings is that really the reason
people have grown tired of you or could
it be could it just be that maybe you've
been looking your whole life for an
excuse as to why why you can't while
other people of the same color race
gender orientation take your pick do you
can't and they do but you know granted
um I I have to say I'm always surprised
it seems like MLK jr. was ahead of his
time I have a dream today
that all men regardless of color of skin
who can pinch a loaf at their local
coffee house without repercussions and
that Shaun King would tweet that hey did
you like this video it what you didn't
oh you're a cat person well that makes
sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video you know what crazy cat you
can get back you couldn't you can
comment below to as to why you don't
like it